on your supplement recommendation for me as of 9.30.24,
would you revise the list in order of importance?
Now, I put this question in here because this person
asked the question and obviously I'm not
going to share their supplement list with everybody
on this thing.
But I put this question here just to remind me
to tell everybody that, yes, I want
to be completely understanding of people's financial situation.
So from a financial situation, this person,
I believe, is in a more relative state of remission
and they could cut down on their supplements.
I get that question.
You know, it's not a common, but I get the question
that, hey, can you put my list in order of importance
for financial reasons.
More so, I get the question.
Can you put my list in order of importance
because I hate taking supplements.
And I'm just not going to take, I just,
I just, I've got supplement burden.
It's really easy when you have a serious disease,
you're willing to do a ton of stuff and take everything
and you get to a point where you do get supplement burden.
That's a real thing.
I get that.
And so, yes, I will hopefully tomorrow look at your list.
And put it in order and I'll email you.
So, I'll email you the list of importance.
One, two, three, four, five.
You can decide what you want to do and what you can do.
That's okay.
Back to this question too, there's a,
and I will also make a note of things that you can pulse.
That's how you can save money and you can save on supplement
taking burnout by pulsing supplements.
So, you may take one every other day
and take a different one.
The opposite every other day,
and it means you'll go twice as far
and you'll take half as many supplements.
So, that's another thing that I may recommend too.